we're going to talk about the best way to get
off sugar now the question is why is it so
hard to give up sugar well the simple answer is
because you're doing it without your body's help
when you try to give up sugar on top of body
cravings it takes a tremendous amount of willpower
and self-discipline you're completely going uphill
and it's just a matter of time before you start
caving in and then going back to sugar but
what if you were completely able to give up
your addictions i'm sorry your cravings once
and for all wouldn't that be a lot easier
yes it really is because what you're dealing
with when you're craving sugar and you're giving
in the sugar is you're really dealing with this
this spike in this one neurotransmitter called
dopamine dopamine gives you pleasure for about
i don't know 90 seconds to two minutes and then
that's followed up with a big spike in cortisol
and then you're going to feel stressed personally
if i ate i don't know about 30 grams of sugar
right now i'd feel like crap i'm gonna feel
lethargic for at least 20 to 30 minutes if not an
hour to two hours i just wouldn't feel quite right
i'd start feeling irritable and grouchy my
vision would be off i would have brain fog
i would have terrible concentration and
i would actually have more sugar cravings
but i think people are used to it and they really
don't even know how good they can feel once they
come off sugar but here's the recommendation
on the correct way to get off sugar number one
don't do it gradually but don't postpone the
misery when you do it gradually you're still
having sugar cravings during this process so some
people try to give up their sugar cravings within
i don't know one to two to three weeks during
the entire time they have sugar cravings i
mean why not just do it within two days and
you're done because once you adapt to ketones
you no longer have cravings they're gone and also
there's no such thing as a sugar detox you're not
detoxifying when you're getting off sugar toxins
are not coming out sugar is being burned up
but what you're feeling is this transition period
on your brain your brain simply just does not have
the fuel it's not toxins it just doesn't have the
fuel because you haven't converted over to ketones
quite yet there's a very simple solution and that
is to start taking ketones in the form of mct oil
so mct oil converts quickly to ketones it feeds
your brain it makes your brain feel happy and
you won't have that bad feeling but you want
to get off sugar very quick very simply start
consuming two meals one at lunch and one at dinner
no snacks and just to keep this simple just make
sure your carbs are less than 30 grams per day
not per meal but per day what's going to happen
is because you're depriving your body of sugar
your body is going to start converting over to
ketosis and your body's going to start to use
this other fuel source and you're going to start
feeling better but the biggest thing you're going
to notice is that your hunger is going to go away
and your cravings are going to go away and it's
not going to take a long time to have that happen
you're looking at about two days and then the
process you're taking this mct oil just to make
it a lot easier anyway i wanted to create this
video on those of you that are still eating sugar
despite watching all my videos week after week as
well as those people that are new to my channel so
if you're enjoying my content which i hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i would really appreciate
you sharing your success story so click the link
down below to my website where you can upload
your success story so you can help inspire others